[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans questions
politiques le rendez vous politique du
dimanche de france inter de france info
la télé et en partenariat avec le
journal le monde celui parce que c'est
un homme qui a accepté notre invitation
jusqu'à 13 heures et depuis trois ans
presque jour pour jour membres du
gouvernement avec un portefeuille
essentiel pour le pouvoir exécutif
puisqu'il est ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement un
portefeuille élargi à la participation
citoyenne une nouveauté qui n'est pas
sans lien avec la crise des gilet jaune
et gilet jaune qui ont tenté hier un
retour timide sur les ronds points sur
fond d'envolée bien réelle des prix des
carburants comment voit-il ce mouvement
lui qui considère qu'il faut entendre ce
qu'ils se sentent des classes et d'un
naturel discret le numéro deux du modem
qui se rêvait ministre de l'agriculture
est un des rares ministres à avoir un
ancrage territorial anciens depuis 25
ans déjà dans le loir et cher ce qui
fait de lui un homme très précieux pour
le pouvoir selon lui justement le
pouvoir at il suffisamment écouté les
territoires et réinventer la démocratie
comme emmanuel macron s'y était engagé
il y a cinq ans et puis comme en lui
l'homme qui se présente comme
raisonnable un homme aussi de compromis
juge-t-il la radicalité de ce début de
campagne présidentielle
il est avec nous pour répondre à ces
questions et à bien d'autres encore
jusqu'à 13h et en direct il est amateur
de chasse à l'arbalète marc raynaud est
l'invité de questions politiques
questions politiques
[Musique]
thomas snégaroff sur france inter
bonjour marc fesneau bonjour vous n'êtes
pas venu avec votre arbalète non non
d'ailleurs mais tant mieux pour nous
pourtant oui pour vous
pour vos tout le monde sait pas les
lieux en plus pour vous poser des
questions je serai comme chaque semaine
accompagné de la banque de questions
politiques nathalie saint cricq de
france télévisions bonjour nathalie
bonjour à tous françoise fressoz ce du
monde bonjour françoise bonjour à tous
et karine becquart de france inter seule
karine salut tout le monde tout à
l'heure nous rejoindre à alexandra
bensaïd pour des questions économiques
on verra notamment la question du
carburant et du pouvoir d'achat avec
alexandra le hashtag question paul pour
vos questions et vos commentaires marc
fesneau on va commencer avec quelque
chose de beaucoup moins souriant hier
notre pays commémorait avec émotion le
premier anniversaire de l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire-géographie décapité en pleine
rue par un islamiste jean michel
blanquer le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a tenu hier à lui rendre
hommage samuel patty a eu raison raison
de faire cours sur la liberté
d'expression raison d'enseigner ce même
raid même ce qui est difficile raison d'
expliquer ce que sont la tolérance
l'humanisme les valeurs de notre
république
nous ne l'oublierons jamais est-ce qu'il
était important pour le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et donc pour vous
au gouvernement de rappeler que samuel
pâtit n'a rien fait de mal qu'il a eu
raison c'est important pour le
gouvernement et c'est important pour
tout le monde j'étais moi-même à une
commémoration dans mon département dans
le loir et cher on inaugurait une place
au nom de samuel patine esplanade avec
un maire qui est d'ailleurs par ailleurs
enseignant d'histoire je pense que pour
tout le monde se souvenir de ce qui est
arrivé ce jour là qui ne n'est pas le
fruit de la folie meurtrière d'un homme
et d'un enchaînement de choses au fond
ça mais elle pâtit avaient été désignés
comme cibles comme si pour ce qu'il
était pour ce qu'ils faisaient c'est à
dire enseigner
enseigner l'ouverture aux autres
enseigner l'ouverture au monde enseigner
le respect des différences enseigner
l'histoire est enseignée l'esprit
critique et au fond il est il est mort
d'enseigner sa mère pattie et c'est
quand même au 21ème siècle qu'on puisse
mourir d'enseigner et qu'on n'oublie pas
qu'il est mort d'enseigner et qu'on
n'oublie pas tous ses collègues au fond
sa famille évidemment mais tous ses
collègues qui chantent jour essaye
d'apprendre ce qu'est l'ouverture au
monde essaie d'apprendre ce que sont nos
valeurs et ce que nous portons je pense
qu'on aurait fait des fois ne pas le
faire il faut c'est un travail
d'ailleurs de l'éducation nationale des
équipes pédagogiques mais je pense que
c'est bien que tout le monde s'en
souvient ce que c'est le travail de tous
ces travail des gouvernements ce travail
des élus beaucoup d'élus locaux s'ils
travaillent sur ces questions et c'est à
ce à quoi il faut essayer de ce ca se
rendre mais ce que vous dites là c'est
un peu ce qu'on disait déjà il ya un nom
c'est alors qu'a changé on depuis lors
alors d'ailleurs pas par un effet de
concomitance des temps le président de
la république avait exprimé des choses
dans un discours qui était resté
marquant pour moi le discours de muro
mais qui était qu un jour d'ailleurs
avant l'assassinât de sa mère pattie
dans lequel ils avaient identifié ce qui
était le mal le risque du séparatisme et
depuis lors il ya des moyens techniques
qui ont été développés parce qu'on voit
bien la puissance dévastatrice dans ces
gars là et elle est souvent d'ailleurs
trop dévastatrices des réseaux sociaux
les moyens qu'on a mis au travers de la
plate forme qui s'appelle pharos si j'ai
bonne mémoire qui permet de détecter
ceux qui ici un enseignant là un
éducateur l'a1 et l'ue sont menacées
pour à raison de telles ou telles
discussions en raison de telles ou
telles expressions et donc c'est là
dessus qu'on a travaillé d'abord et puis
de au travers de la loi sur les
principes républicains pourraient
affirmer les principes républicains et
se doter de moyens supplémentaires mais
avide association vis-à-vis de lieux de
culte par exemple qui viennent enseigner
de séparatistes des choses qu'on a on a
on a plutôt avancer sur un certain
nombre de sujets après après faut être
modeste et réseaux et comment dire elle
est résolue dans l'action et en même
temps montrer que c'est un travail de
temps l'on voit bien que tu es un
travail de temps donc est à faire est-ce
que c'est pas aussi un travail de
transmission par exemple dominique
schnapper qui préside le conseil des
sages de la laïcité estime qu' on a une
mauvaise transmission aujourd'hui de ce
qu'est la laïcité aux plus jeunes
générations est ce que vous partagez
sont inquiètes oui on a sans doute vécu
sur un acquis en disant c'est fait s'est
posée c'est d'ailleurs une exception
française la laïcité face au dessus de
la sita la france ya une laïcité de la
cité on a une conception
de ces questions là qui est particulière
à la france et qui est assez forte moi
je trouve son d'être en perte de vitesse
et ses jeunes et sans doute at-on oublié
de ce qu'ont été les fondements de
rappeler que ce n'était pas d'ailleurs
une bataille en droit des religions mais
c'était la capacité à chacun de vivre sa
foi ou sa non fois devises y pense ce
qui ne pensent pas de façon libre et en
respectant l'autre c'est le respect de
ce qu'on pense et le respect de ce que
les autres pensent au fond et je pense
qu'on a besoin de l'enseigné et c'est
pas une affaire seulement deux religions
voit bien qu'on est dans une société on
en reviendra on y reviendra peut-être
tout à l'heure où on a du mal à pouvoir
exprimer des différences sans que ce
soit une violence qu'il soit fait à
l'autre et moi je pense que c'est un
sujet dans le monde dans le monde à
table et c'est ce que je trouvais est ce
que vous trouvez par fournée des obsédés
de la laïcité a notamment du côté des
corbières qui a dit qu'il considérait
qu'on alain petit peu trop loi notamment
dans la volonté de montrer un certain
nombre de caricatures il ya un paradoxe
dans un sondage chez les jeunes est à la
fois 63% un sondage ifop qui considère
que la laïcité en danger puis d'un autre
côté ils trouvent que c'est trop présent
dans le débat est ce que trouvé que
cette exception française est excessive
moi je pense que ça n'est pas une
question de fond c'est une question de
forme c'est la façon dont on exprime
j'essaie de les exprimer avec des mots
qu'ils soient des mots plutôt de
l'apaisement que les mots de la querelle
sans n'a pas la farlède intégrisme laïc
mais je pense qu'il faut faire attention
à rester sur ce qu'ont été les
fondements de la laïcité et pas quelque
chose qui donne s'apparente à une espèce
de police de la laïcité
mais il faut croire que son c'est quoi
la police de la laïcité c'est le
sentiment qu'on peut donner parfois
d'aller trop loin ou de donner le
sentiment que ce n'est pas une question
de respect des croyances mais question
de bataille de croyance est ce qu'il est
risqué donc on n'a pas à rentrer dans
cette dans cette querelle là il me
semble que là qu'il a très bien fait
rire c'est de respecter les principes de
la république et qu' il n'y a pas de loi
supérieure de ce point de vue là est par
ailleurs de respecter les croyances est
ce que jean michel blanquer flirte avec
cette politique considère qu'il a
réaffirmée en bien des occasions ces
principes
et moi je trouve ça juste dans le monde
en convient parce qu'on a vécu aussi
toute une période dont on disait au fond
une espèce de renoncement permanent j'ai
pas si c'est ce que pense monsieur
corbère je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs au
fond mais de renoncement permanent de
peu de petits reculs en petit recul on a
fini par accepter des choses qui ne
l'étaient peut-être pas forcément rêver
est ce que c'est pas trop tard je pense
qu'on peut pas être responsable public
et même d'ailleurs être responsable tout
court et penser que c'est trop tard je
pense non certains cela je pense que ces
choses et notamment l'évolution des
mentalités chez les jeunes mais jeu mais
je pense que c'est à la douche sanex pas
que la question de la laïcité il faut
qu'on gros on retrouve l'esprit civique
et ce n'est pas un grief et aux jeunes
et aux moins jeunes d'ailleurs c'est une
oeuvre collective qui doit être la nôtre
qui est d'être en capacité de respecter
en fait le le sujet fondamental là
dedans c'est le respect de la différence
et le respect de l'autre et c'est une
affaire de réciprocité ça ça s'enseigne
ça sert la politique c'est intéressant
que vous parlez de ça parce que cette
semaine jean michel blanquer encore lui
a lancé son laboratoire de la république
une sorte de think tank de ré cercle de
réflexion qui cible selon lui l'un des
principaux dangers qui va miner notre
jeunesse qui est selon lui le wac isme
alors photo expliquer ce qu'est le web
qui ce moque isme c'est une idéologie
selon laquelle les minorités ferai tout
pour faire passer en avant leurs
différences au détriment se sait ceux
qui le critiquent 1 au détriment de
l'universalisme qui fonderait notre
république et c'est définir assez vite
est ce que vous considérez que
précisément il en fait pas trop et
qu'ils ciblent les bonnes menace alors
que vous dites justement qu'il faut
penser aussi aux différences est-ce que
c'est pas à braser les différences que
de dire les mots qui se sont aimés
respecter la différence n'est pas faire
que les uns et les autres se battent sur
leurs différences les respecter c'est
dans l'idée de haut qu'ils m'en parti
que je trouve que j'avais plutôt bien
défini tout cas je me retrouve et c'est
compréhensible pour chacun d'entre nous
il ya l'idée quand même que la minorité
viendrait aussi imposé à la majorité la
majorité n'est pas là pour imposer à la
minorité mais la réciproque est vraie au
fond et simplement il faut qu'on
respecte chacun dans sa différence et
donc ça ne me gêne pas du tout et je
partage complètement le point de vue de
jean michel blanquer que nous soyons
dans une logique on ne cultive pas ce
qui nous sépare mais qu'on cultive ce
qui nous rapproche tout en respectant ce
que nous sommes les uns et les autres et
vous répondez pas à la question de le
move est trop fort mais de la fracture
générationnelle est ce que les jeunes
défendent cette notion de laïcité de la
même façon que des gens n'ont alors et
au delà et au delà de la laïcité la
question des différences d de l'égalité
réelle entre les citoyen ça c'est une
question qui est beaucoup la jeunesse
français je pense que d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas dédié complètement des sujets
de monde dans lequel on vit qui est qu a
plutôt fait la promotion de
l'individualisme et l'individu est
d'ailleurs le système économique que
nous avons construit pas nous depuis 50
ans depuis 60 ans il s'est plutôt un
compte à ce qu'un un système économique
qui parle aux individus plutôt qu'au
collectif qui a plutôt intérêt à avoir
des consommateurs que des citoyens c'est
comme ça qu'on a construit alors je fais
pas de griefs aux générations
précédentes c'est comme ça c'est ce
qu'on a sous les yeux et donc c'est
l'ensemble du modèle qu'il faut repenser
me semble-t-il parce que si on est
simplement sûr on vient traiter au fond
les symptômes et pas les causes des
causes profondes c'est qu'on a créé une
situation d'individus dans lesquels je
suis moi même je veux dire de leçon à
personne sur le sujet et donc je sais
pas si c'est qu'une fracture
générationnelle parce qu'il ya aussi sa
yo cij dans chez les jeunes la volonté
pour beaucoup d'entre eux de s'engager
pour défendre des causes la question
écologique est une question qui n'est
pas une question individuelle c'est une
question collective la question du
réchauffement climatique n'est pas un
sujet individuel parce que si c'est
individuel on pourrait dire attendons
que les chinois les américains et
d'autres fassent l'effort puisque nous
nous avons déjà fait notre porte et la
grande tolérance qui monte vis-à-vis des
autres religions c'est aussi du
collectif et pas d'individus absolument
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut essayer
de construire et donc c'est une affaire
générationnel mais je suis pas si tout
le monde est responsable de la situation
dans laquelle on est et tout le monde
doit cultiver 7,7 à la fois cette ce
respect de la différence et en même
temps l'idée qu'on est ensemble et que
la différence c'est pas ce qui nous
réunit par nature en soit je ne vous
fera pas que en plaine le pré campagne
présidentielle ce thème là d'eau font
comment on vit avec les autres comme on
en entend l'autre soit aussi absentes du
discours public pour l'instant bailly
les îles égéennes effectuera alors j'ai
une question complémentaire vous qui
êtes souvent pour le coup dans les
territoires l'expression n'est pas très
joli mais en tout cas de pas à paris est
ce que c'est des choses que vous
entendez aussi où c'est un délire
parisiano parisien journalistique
ne trouverez jamais dans cette facilité
de taper sur paris les journalistes
assez peu quand même naîtrait les cas
non je n'essaie pas de ne pas me livrer
à ces caricatures là non plus parce que
je pense que c'est pas répondre à la
caricature par la caricature
ça existe ce sens ce sentiment là ce qui
est enfin on peut pas dire ça soit pas
dans le débat parce qu'il ya des gens
qui disent exactement l inverse de ce
que je dis ce qui n'est pas dans le
débat c'est la volonté justement de
faire de vrais collectivement et cesser
de passer par un séparer les gens je
vois beaucoup de gens qui essaient de
séparer les gens au compteur donc c'est
vraiment pas le débat par un effet
miroir par un effet miroir ya des gens
qui aujourd'hui dans le débat veulent
eux mêmes critiques en l'exacerbation
des différences exacerbe les différences
parce qu'au fond ils disent ils sont
différents parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
même religion ils sont différents parce
que donc c'est ça qui pose un problème
et donc on a on a besoin de ça existe
partout pour répondre je pense que cette
suis pas sûr que ce soit un sujet du
quotidien
comme vous et moi on vit parfois normes
comme vous tous oui parfois normalement
aussi on croise des gens je pense que ce
soit tous les matins les obsessions de
certains mais enfin ça existe ce
sentiment qui est un sentiment aussi lié
à la question de qu'est ce qu'on est
qu'est-ce qu'on est comme nation qu'est
ce qu'on porte comme valeur voilà qui
semble d'identité au bon sens du terme
justement cette question qu'est-ce qu'on
est comme nation elle se pose en
particulier aujourd'hui le 17 octobre
2021 puisqu'il ya 60 ans jour pour jour
la police parisienne réprimé avec une
violence inouïe une manifestation
pacifiste d'algériens de la région
parisienne venue à paris à l'appel du
fln pour je répète pour les gens pour
demander la fin du couvre-feu qu'il est
ciblé mais aussi pour réclamer
l'indépendance de l'algérie hier le
président de la république emmanuel
macron a fait ce qu'aucun président
n'avait jamais fait avant lui il a
assisté à une cérémonie en hommage aux
dizaines de victimes longtemps niée par
la france et dans le communiqué de
l'elysée emmanuel macron a précisé qu'il
s'agissait de crimes inexcusable pour la
république est-ce que et ça a été
beaucoup critiquée depuis c'est
suffisant de n'évoquer que la figure de
maurice papon et de ne pas parler de
crime d'état au fond depuis des années
sur ces questions-là en globalement de
mémoire collective on a toujours eu le
choix entre une forme d'amnésie ou une
forme de repentance c'était amnésie ou
repentance et le présent de la
république depuis le début de son
quinquennat et même avant au fond dans
la campagne présidentielle
il a plus au choix zee devrait en disant
si on veut qu'ils aient de la
réconciliation il faut qu'on dise les
choses telles qu'elles se sont passées
je prends souvent dans ce genre de
moment à ce qu'il fait il faudrait
regarder ce qu'avait fait l'afrique du
sud au moment de la fin de l'apartheid
il avait créé une commission qui
s'appelait vérité et réconciliation
réconciliation qui partait de quel
principe au fond qui pouvait pas y avoir
de réconciliation sans qu'on dit ce qui
s'était passé absolument et que c'était
de part et d'autre que la vérité devait
être exprimés et que peut-être il faut
qu'on essaie de construire avec nos amis
algériens la vérité de part et d'autre
parce que oui non mais nous considèrent
non je parle des citoyens algériens je
veux dire on ne peut pas on va pas se
faire la guerre entre les peuples on a
une histoire commune qu'est longue enfin
je les ai dit on a des liens qui sont
très profonds moi je vous me trouverez
pas sur la sur le terrain de dire que ce
sont des adversaires désignés on peut
avoir des débats y compris des débats
virulents avec les responsables
politiques mais nous faisons notre part
il faut que chacun fasse sa part parce
que je pense que la réconciliation elle
passe par la vérité réciproque est
d'ailleurs dans cette commission en
afrique du sud il y avait des crimes
qu'ils avaient été commis par l'état
tenant l'apartheid et par aussi ceux qui
avaient essayé lutte et la tendresse et
la des partisans de l' insee et je
trouve que c'est ça la force de la
vérité c'est quand elle est partagée de
façon responsable et rencontré position
si je veux la résumer dit mme aussi ce
fut une erreur ces ouvertures des
archives des deux côtés et travail de
l'histoire des deux côtés il me suit
réciprocité des algériens ça n'est pas
en offrant un salaire décent est bien
partie pour ça pour l'instant certes
mais ça n'empêche pas d'essayer
d'oeuvrer sur ce chemin avec le ton que
j'emploie qui n'est pas un ton corps et
leur je pense que c'est cette vérité
elle est nécessaire pour les français
est nécessaire pour les iron mémorielle
c'est une erreur de paris sa et et cette
réconciliation et les noms et cette
réconciliation elle est nécessaire vous
êtes ministre en charge des relations
avec le parlement est ce que le
parlement doit légiférer sur ces
questions mémorielles en souvient qu'en
2005 la loi sur les jeux par une
direction qui est très mal passée parlé
au ministre des relations avec le
parlement je pense qu'on a parfois une
propension on a essayé d'éviter cet
écueil d'un durant ce quinquennat mais
les précédents n'ont pas été avares de
cette question à chaque fois qu'on a un
problème on fait une loi ou à chaque
fois qu'on a une question fait loi je
pense qu'on a mal la loi ça va mais à
deux vous convient après on vient la
question de la mémoire la question de la
vérité n'est pas une question de loi
c'est une question d'attitude et de la
façon dont on le met dans le débat
public voyez bien sûr la question
précise que vous évoquez
et le sujet du 17 octobre 1961 il était
donc il ya 60 ans ce n'est pas une
question de faire une loi pour dire
voilà la vérité la question c'est dire
voilà ce qui s'est passé reconnaissance
qui s'est passé et donc je trouve que
cette propension à trop légiférer
je mets en garde sur ce cerise sur ces
sujets là je trouve que c'est très très
dangereux de poids la
france inter
[Musique]
question politique
thomas snégaroff et voici alexandra
bensaïd qui s'assoient à mes côtés il va
donc s'agir de quelques questions
d'économie et de sujets du quotidien
bonjour marc fait bonjour marc fesneau
vous êtes un ministre de terrain hier
vous étiez dans la sarthe auparavant
dans les yvelines dans l'aisne moi
j'aimerais savoir ce que les élus vous
dise du ressenti des français qu'est-ce
qui remonte en ce moment du terrain ont
comme tous les autres collègues on est
sur le terrain c'est bien normal je
trouve que ce que les élus remonte c'est
d'abord quand même le sentiment assez
profond que pour la première fois on
arrive à se retrouver vraiment sans la
crainte n'a reçu épidémique même s'il
faut être vigilant
au fond tout le monde est heureux
d'avoir à la fois mis en place d un
certain nombre de dispositions les élus
ont mis en place les vaccinodromes donc
pour beaucoup d'entre eux les citoyens
ont suivi globalement voilà et le
bonheur d'être ensemble de nouveaux
premiers éléments deuxième élément pour
faire vite
quand même le sentiment que la reprise
est au rendez vous qu'on a évité le pire
à l'époque et nous n'avions pas eu un
deuxième voire un troisième confinement
l'an dernier à la même époque il y avait
quand même une vraie crainte est un vrai
trouble y compris dans l'opinion mais
évidemment auprès auprès des
responsables publics et c'est de se dire
quelle va être la situation du pays un
an plus tard et un an plus tard et
pourtant avec des épisodes épidémiques
ont continué à monter il se trouve que
la situation économique est plutôt
satisfaisante en termes d de création
d'emplois et de croissance alors après
ça ça reflète des réalités différentes
et puis un troisième sujet parce que je
m'en voudrais de ne pas l'évoquer si le
sujet pouvoir d'achat parce qu'on a un
sujet autour des des matières premières
et en particulier des matières premières
énergétiques c'est le retour de laval à
0 c'est au fond on a été sortis de la
crise on se sent ni terre où ont
commencé à regarder des éléments
économiques qui ont continué à avoir des
éléments économiques et sociaux qui sont
favorables et puis une petite lumière
s'allume en feu orange si je peux dire
pour dire attention il ya un sujet alors
justement le feu orange trois ans après
le mouvement des gilet jaune certains
d'entre eux auraient investi hier des
ronds points c'était à caen orléans a
nice on les a vus en alsace en vendée on
va pas on ne va pas dire que le
mouvement était massif mais vous parlez
de lumière orange est ce que vous pensez
que une éruption de colère est possible
est ce que ça vous inquiète de revoir
des gilet jaune il faut toujours être
vigilant sur les mouvements
je pense que c'est pas tout à fait de
même nature ce qu'il faut quand même
rappeler les choses là même la dernière
fois ci je veux dire en 2018 la question
carburant a été montée parce qu'il y
avait à la fois une concomitance de vaud
la hausse des carburants et puis la
concomitance de l'apparition d'une taxe
c'est comme ça qu'est né le sujet
avec un sentiment qu'on ne comprenait
pas avec les gens étaient dans des
impasses alors là d'abord rappeler quand
même que la hausse des carburants je
sais que ce gouvernement est responsable
de tout et surtout quand ça va pas mais
en tout cas pour nous opposant mais la
hausse des carburants c'est une hausse
des carburants mondiale et dans tous les
pays du monde ça se savait ce qu'on a à
faire c'est de faire en sorte qu'on a
fait par exemple sur les questions de
chauffage de gaz en particulier de
trouver des mécanismes d'amorties sage
des mécanismes qui permettent d'amortir
ses plus français la question de la
hausse le choc est sûre le choc durant
la période parce que en gros si on dit
qu'il y avait un centime de plus si mes
calculs sont bons et pour avoir une
mémoire assez précis de ces sujets là ça
fait 10 euros par plein et donc cette
question assez vite en dix semaines ça
fait femme n'est allé si c'est un plein
par semaine on va dire ça peut créer
cette question là donc on va le premier
ministre sous l'autorité du président de
la république elle aimait les ministres
concernés feront un certain non sans
doute de proposition dans la semaine
pour essayer après ce qu'on a fait sur
les questions de chauffage tournage elle
une neutralisation des hausses de
regarder ce qu'on peut faire sur la
question des carburants les de
l'automobile vous titre que le
gouvernement que l'exécutif n'est pas
responsable de tout mais quand même sur
le prix payé à la pompe 60 % de la
facture
c'est donc il ne bouge pas c'est pas les
taxes qui font la hausse ce qui fait la
hausse et la hausse de la matière
première et les taxes ils ont toujours
existé je crois pas que ce gouvernement
les augmenter mais si palm ans depuis
des années le modèle fiscal français
d'un modèle qui taxent beaucoup les
carburants mais y'a des leviers donc il
y a le levier des détaxes anne hidalgo
propose de faire baisser la tva par
exemple de 20% à 5 et 10% pour la même
et dargaud qui dit qu'il faut pas
favoriser les carburants fossiles une
somme bien on parle bien de la même
personne donc ça dépanne mais je te
plante non mais c'est pas ça jeudi il
faut juste rechercher la cohérence de
ceux qui font la chasse aux véhicules à
moteur diesel et essence sans
distinction d'ailleurs qu'ils fassent
des favorise plutôt les plus modestes
d'entre nous en dix ans et je veux pas
qu'ils viennent à paris qui dit faux
baisser la tva pour qui alors au fond
oui chacun cherche à cohérence
évidemment tu sais ça fait partie de
l'éventail des outils ya du déchet est
intéressant de chèques étaient mes
soeurs de ce genre de propositions quand
il vient de vous donner des leçons sur
il ya trop de voitures à moteur
thermique il ya aussi les chaque essence
comme chez xavier bertrand oui 20 euros
par mois est ce que pour vous êtes vous
connaissez bien le terrain vous
connaissez le via la ruralité est ce que
ça c'est intéressant mais c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs je trouve que on
serait on serait comme on dit région on
serait bien dans le débat public ce que
j'entends que monsieur bertrand commence
déjà à dire voyez reprenne mes idées
simplement d'essayer de poser les
problèmes essayer de trouver des
solutions est arrivé qu'on trouve aussi
des solutions et donc celle là fait
partie de la panoplie tous
que le week-end la mécanisme du chèque
permet aussi de ne pas le faire de
manière indistincte être ça permet aussi
de distinguer ceux qui sont en vraie
difficulté pour des questions de revenus
et ceux qui le sont moins pour ces
questions de carburant donc on va
regarder ne m'appartient pas de dire
qu'elles sont et en particulier pas
aujourd'hui puisque ce sera la semaine
prochaine de dire ce qui ce qui sera
fait par le gouvernement en tout cas
nous avons déjà lens la semaine
prochaine la semaine prochaine ou dans
les dans les 15 jours au caire puisqu'on
est dans le moment budgétaire en plus
hasard du calendrier si je peux dire est
donc en tout cas le premier ni jean
castex il est très vigilants sur ces
questions là et nous sommes tous parce
qu'on voit bien ce que ça peut produire
comme effet pour un certain nombre de
gens pour qui la voiture est le seul
moyen possible
de locomotion et le changement à
l'électrique n'est pas forcément aussi
facile que ça et donc dans ce moment où
on pas mettre les gens dans des impasses
faut qu'on trouve des solutions le temps
pour le coup sûr c'est en tout cas sur
les carburants et c'est ce qu'on peut
espérer que la tension baisse oui alors
dans les mesures phares des gilet jaune
en 2018 et puis aussi dans les cahiers
de doléances il y avait le retour de
l'isf marc fesneau je voudrais vous
faire écouter une archive nous sommes le
15 janvier 2019 en normandie et c'est
emmanuel macron qui lance le grand débat
faut pas raconter des craques c'est pas
parce qu'on remettra lisf comme il était
un an et demi que la situation d'un seul
gilet jaune s'améliorera c'est de la
peep cette réforme elle doit être évalué
les parlementaires dont c'est le coeur
de métier au sénat à l'assemblée ils
vont regarder ce qui marche qui marche
pas si des mesures ont été prises durant
ces vingt mois qui n'ont pas des faits
qui ne sont pas pertinentes ou qui sont
contre productives elles seront
corrigées faut être avant tout d'un
grand pragmatisme et j'essaie de l'être
alors il faut être très clair
l'évaluation elle a été faite ya même eu
trois rapports est ce que baisser la
fiscalité du capital c'est à dire les
réformes fiscales du début du
quinquennat est-ce que ça ruisselle ou
alors si vous n'aimez pas le mot est ce
que ça permet non balles apparemment
vous lassez pas que non on peut ne pas
détesté ils sont appréciés je prends
moore whissell alors prenez le mot est
ce que ça ruisselle est ce que l'argent
est investi dans l'économie des
entreprises et bien les experts de
francs stratégie qui ce qui est donc un
organisme rattaché à matignon on nous
dise pour la troisième fois que vraiment
on ne voit aucun effet est-ce que pour
vous ministre de ce gouvernement c'est
un problème alors d'abord rappelé que
cette expertise vous avez raison de le
rappeler elle a été faite à la demande
du gouvernement c'est pas souvent un car
devant un gouvernement demande qu'on
puisse juger sa propre politique fiscale
fin jeudi au passage nos j'aurais aimé
que les prédécesseurs le fasse et
j'imagine que les successeurs que
j'espère lointain mais le souci c'est
quand même déjà comprendre ça c'est
voilà mamie sign aux noms mais
je l'air de badiner mais c'est pas que
sur la forme parce que je pense que non
mais la question de l'évaluation je
trouve que dans le débat public et
politique en cavale derrière démesurée
que jamais on évalue et confond personne
ne fait ce qu'on a fait par exemple sur
le texte sur la d états généraux de
l'alimentation et galim on a vu ce qui
marchait dans les galipes on a vu ce qui
marchait pas on a un deuxième texte qui
permet de corriger balle au fond c'est
aux bénéfices alors je finis sur la
question du sfg j'ai parcouru ce rapport
les experts disent deux choses 1 on ne
voit pas de choses avérées et entre eux
mêmes ils sont pas tout à fait d'accord
pas tout à fait en dix ans c'est
peut-être un peu tôt il nous aura pas
énorme c'est peut-être un peu tôt pour
certains c'est ce que dit un certain
nombre d'experts deuxième chose moi ce
que je constate je sais pas ce qu'elle
est la part de l' isf autres ce que je
constate c'est que nous sommes le pays
d'europe où l'un des pays d'europe mais
je parle sous l'oeil du spécialiste donc
vous me corrigerez sans doute qu'ils
avaient bénéficié le plus
d'investissements ces dernières années
et l'investissement dans les entreprises
c'est quand même ce qui compte pour
créer des emplois et de la richesse dans
ce pays premier élément deuxième élément
on est un pays où ce qui était un
mouvement général parce qu'au fond les
gens à échapper à l'impôt en partie en
partant à l'étranger et le mouvement et
c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs le rapport
en partie face à sète le steward iwuy
attendait juste il dit il ya les exilés
fiscaux ont fait mouvement inverse pour
quelques centaines win sur 130 une
accord mais personne qui paie s'est
passé suffisent pas non mais faut pas
dire qu'il ya un sujet d'exilés fiscaux
si ces quelques 500 ses antennes à ce
moment-là n'en parlons pas mais comme
tout le monde a parlé des exilés fiscaux
que nous constations le fait qu' il ya
comment dirais-je
il ya moins d'exilés fiscaux contraire
il ya un mouvement inverse bien et
troisième chose on est on reste quand
même le pays en termes de capitalisation
du capital qui est le deuxième plus
élevé je crois derrière le danemark si
j'ai bonne mémoire bon donc on a une
taxation qui est forte en même temps
qu'on donne le signal que le choix qu'on
a fait depuis le début qu'ils aient le
choix de du développement économique
développement industriel parce que
derrière c'est de l'emploi je pense que
c'est un bon choix marc fesneau quand
même ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il ya donc
pas pour l'instant en tout cas si vous
le présenter comme ça des faits pour la
majorité des français pour l'économie en
général en revanche ce qui est bien
documentée dans le rapport c'est que ça
a eu un effet mesurable sur la
concentration des dividendes chez les
plus riches donc l'étiquette président
des riches elle n'est pas décoller mais
c'est inexact parce que nous sommes le
quinquennat parce qu'il faut tout mettre
dans une balance dans lequel le pouvoir
d'achat ça aussi c'est un rapport
d'expert alors je ne trie pas dans les
rapports d'experts qui dit que nous
sommes le quinquennat dans lequel le
pouvoir d'achat aura le plus augmenté
pour tous les français et en particulier
d'ailleurs pour les français les plus
modestes que c'est inversement
proportionnée c'est ce que dit un
rapport parce que je ne trie pas les
reins
c'est le cd je crois qu'ils disent à l
insee qui disent à des organismes plutôt
indépendant me semble utile 8% caen dans
les deux précédents quinquennat cumulé 7
et 4 % c'est ça la réalité des français
s'il s'agit des grandes crises il
l'effaçait quinquennat il ya eu plus de
pouvoir c'est en tout cas ce qu'ont vécu
ce qu'est ce qui est la réalité des
chefs parlementaires avant la fin
non mais c'est assez de ce sont des
moyennes par nature les moyennes de ce
que j'ai dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
avec grosse que la terre doivent
corriger marque l'école et comme l'a dit
le chef de l'état dans leur forfait vous
avez raison on l'a toujours de dire ça
parce qu'on l'a toujours fait quand on a
vu qu'ils avaient des éléments qui
nécessitait des corrections on fera donc
on regardera à chaque fois qu'ils aient
besoin de corriger de lire on peut
ajuster on le fera merci alexandre
bensaïd
france inter
question politique marc fesneau vous
avez parlé des gilet jaune avec
alexandra bensaïd j'aimerais revenir
avec un billet peut-être plus politique
qu'économique vous êtes ministre en
charge des relations avec le parlement
et de la participation citoyenne
d'abord ça veut dire quoi et puis on va
voir si le lien avec les gilet jaune
l'objectif qui est qui préside à la
l'extension aux fêtes du périmètre de
relations avec le parlement à celui de
la participation citoyenne c'est d'abord
le lien entre les deux que le mettre
dans le même périmètre que ça une
logique que je dis pas ça parce que je
suis sur ce ces fonctions là aujourd'hui
c'est parce que je pense que l'idée
qu'on peut nourrir un sentiment
d'opposition entre la démocratie de la
représentation la démocratie directe on
continue ou citoyennes comme mon voeu
est une erreur je pense que les deux
nourrices qu'on a besoin d'avoir un
dialogue entre les citoyens et il ya
quelque chose et les ceux qui les
représentent deuxième chose on a on est
dans un dans un moment de la vie
publique et pas qu'en france d'ailleurs
où les citoyens n'ont pas envie de
donner un quitus pour 5,6 selon la durée
daily mail pour cinq ou six ans
ils ont besoin ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie continue ils ont besoin qu'on
continue sur un certain nombre de sujets
c'est valable au niveau local et c'est
sans doute valable au niveau national et
puisse être interrogé il ya parfois des
sujets comment dire qu'ils sont
d'ampleur nationale qui quittent qui
traversent la société qui nécessite
qu'on ait un débat à l'échelle nationale
et nous aurons fait dans ce cas un
certain nombre d'avancées moi je trouve
on a beaucoup critiqué la convention
citoyenne sur le climat dont qui avait
rendu ses 144 propositions en juin et
votre portefeuille est devenu à la
participation citoyen en juillet dont
j'ai un lien entre les résultats la
critique et on mérite allemand infondées
non plus mais je trouve que c'est
injuste je voudrais pas le résultat de
ce qu'ils ont produit je vais vous dire
ce qui est un succès lui s'il n'y avait
pas eu cette convention citoyenne sur le
climat et donc c'est un hommage qu'il
faut rendre à la fois l'initiative du
président de la république aux citoyens
et beaucoup vous le disent pas ce qu'on
a vu les plus les plus virulents sur les
plateaux télévision mais beaucoup vous
dise il ya des sujets qui nous auraient
jamais été mis à l'ordre du jour la
question de l'artificialisation des sols
la question des transports y compris la
place de la viande dans notre pays c'est
des sujets qui n'étaient pas sur la
table la question de l'alimentation
durable en particulier des circuits
courts la question de la publicité alors
on n'a pas été aussi loin que ceux qui
viennent tous les jours sur les sur les
estrades vous expliquer qu'il ya qu'à
faut qu'on sait si simple mais
l'exercice que j'ai pas dit et voulant
jeu de g sur les prix de l'énergie est
au fond rien n'a été résolu avec la
convention citoyenne on a même évacué
l'histoire de la taxe car madame à la
madame fressoz vous êtes ou pas on peut
partager ensemble l'idée que ce genre de
mouvement et ce genre de transition ce
sont des transitions longue absolument
parce que si j'en avais dit par exemple
sur la question de l'aviation ont
interdit toutes les lignes d'aviation il
ya un certain nombre de territoires
j'étais l'autre jour à clermont ferrand
où les lignes ont été du fait de la
coved et à préparer ouverte pour des
raisons y compris de rentabilité et
aussi de transition écologique comme des
gens qui se sentent délaissés dans ces
affaires-là d'autres faut avoir l'esprit
libre accès des mouvements et ses jo
réfléchir à ce moment là quels
mécanismes mettre en place ce que je
rappelle que le jury de l'énergie
augmentent ardent là je rampe avant
l'annoncé des nouvelles mesures pour
l'impression je rappelle que la question
qui était posée aux citoyens était une
question très simple et en même temps
très complexe dans ses solutions qui
était moins 40% à l'horizon 2030 donc
c'est pas la question de savoir si on
continue à utiliser du diesel et
l'essence c'est comment on en sort comme
en ondes et carbone comme un furieux -
quel enfer à venir axée marque renault
le moyen de locomotion c'est le logement
c'est l'alimentation sans doute et la
construction voilà c'est ça les sujets
sur lequel il faut qu'on avance et donc
c'est tout à fait délier la question du
prix des carburants qui est un problème
de carburant carbonées cela veut dire et
après la transition y compris la
transition électrique on peut partager
le sentiment que ce n'est pas en 12 mois
ou dix huit mois qu'on peut changer 10
millions de véhicules parce que là on va
se retrouver aussi avec des citoyens qui
vont nous dire vous êtes très sympa avec
vos propositions mais tim le paye le
véhicule c'est ça aussi la réalité des
gens et donc alors j'assume le fait qu'
on puisse faire de la participation
citoyenne et j'en finis juste là dessus
et qu'en même temps on prenne nos
responsabilités il ya un an ce qu'on
doit aux citoyens je vais vous le dire
je les dis vendredi dans la convention
citoyenne sur l'europe qui portait par
clément bonne et je trouve que c'est
très bien qu'on fasse ça sur l'europe
c'est qu'on vous doit des comptes aux
citoyens c'est qu'on vous dit pourquoi
on peut faire pourquoi on peut pas faire
alors justement c'est vraiment la vérité
c'est pourquoi on a des airs que nos
c'est un peu là dessus que je voulais je
voulais qu'on aille ensemble parce que
ministre de la participation citoyenne
est ce que vous considérez à la fin du
quinquennat on est quand même dans les
derniers mois du quinquennat que la
démocratie a été réinventée qu'on a
remis de l'air dans le fonctionnement de
la démocratie dans ce pays que les
oppositions étaient davantage écoutés
que la démocratie directe à progresser
alors sur la question de la
participation citoyenne je trouve que
l'expérience de la de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat a été été une
expérience réussie dans son fondement de
ce qu'est comment donne la parole aux
citoyens et d'ailleurs d'autres d'autres
initiatives ont lieu j'ai dit sur la
question de l'europe ce que je pense que
l'europe le sujet de l'europe c'est que
lcl fini par donner le sentiment citoyen
qu'elle se fait sans ou contre eux et
donc on a besoin d'associer des citoyens
participation citoyenne ça demande
beaucoup de méthodologie de
professionnels il sait pas la sphère de
réunir les gens dans la salle de dire
dites nous ce que vous pensez et on fera
comme on veut c'est pas du tout ça la
participation citoyenne c'est une
affaire et c'est une affaire comme vous
le savez qui datent de longue date
notamment dans l'est c'est intéressant
de voir quelle a été plutôt développé
dans les collectivités locales suisses
allemandes en particulier historiquement
gare de carentan ou à d'autres d'autres
collectivités je pense que c'est
intéressant de regarder ce qui c'est
pourquoi il avait fait ça dans les
collectivités locales c'est qu'ils
sentaient bien que des décisions qui
étaient pris mais si comprise si je vous
pose la question marc raynaud c'est
aussi parce que attendez on sort de la
crise sanitaire et que la crise
sanitaire a été pour beaucoup l'équipe
nationale de la verticalité je peux
finir justement je sais ce sur quoi j'ai
donc ça c'est une part qui a été fait je
regrette qu'on n'ait pas pu aller plus
au bout sur la question de la réforme
constitutionnelle ou institutionnel que
nous avions initiée pour les raisons que
vous savez qu'après quand même les
crises successives et le calendrier
parlementaire que je connais bien et les
crises sanitaires ce pas pour donner des
excuses c'est comme ça dans la vie
politique vous avez des objectifs on a
atteint beaucoup d'objectifs il ya des
choses sur lesquelles n'a pas pu avancer
reconnaissons aussi parce que dans nos
oppositions n'est pas une envie folle
d'avancer sur ce sujet constitutionnel
ainsi levé sur la proportionnelle est
une autre façon d'associer bien sûr on
aurait pu faire quelque chose oui mais
je pense que tout ça important c'est un
point le bémol j'ai besoin de chercher à
wazemmes on aimait à biens des ce et 1.2
bémol que je peux voir françois bayrou
et j'en ai très peu c'est je pense que
ou avec mes amis du modem c'est que je
pense que le sujet de la proportionnelle
ne résume pas à lui seul le sujet
démocratique dans la proportion rim et
je pense que la réforme institutionnelle
ou démocratique est un tout
la proportionnelle sans qu'on ait
rééquilibrer le pouls les pouvoirs du
parlement la proportion et ça c'est une
affaire constitutionnel c'est pas une
affaire institutionnellement la
proportionnelle sans qu'on ait repenser
la question du lien entre les
territoires et les élus nationaux les
élus locaux les élus nationaux et qu'on
fasse pas vivre deux écosystèmes qui
s'affrontent la proportionnelle sans
qu'on ait pensé aussi à question
convient d'évoquer de la démocratie
participative tout ça est un tout et
donc je pense qu'on aura avancé sur la
question la démocratie par ailleurs on
voit bien alors est ce que c'est une
urgence pour le prochain quinquennat je
pas si c'est une urgence en tout cas
c'est un débat présidentiel nous
semble-t-il mais est ce que ça peut
lutter contre le l'abstention et le fort
je vais me soigner un autre fois on
pressent pour que les gens aient compris
on parlait des jeunes tout à l'heure et
envie de voter il faut qu'ils qui
perçoivent l'enjeu
et qu'ils aient le sentiment que nous
sommes capables de changer des choses
c'est ça qui nourrit elle qui sont
impliqués aussi oui mais mai et qui sont
appliquées troisième élément mais je les
jeux les jeux je vais déjà d'idées le
sentiment s'est trop souvent développé
chez d'une sitôt nos concitoyens que au
fond ça il n'y avait rien pas de
différence entre les acteurs qui se
présentait et 2 que ça changeait rien de
toute façon on peut l'appliquer à
d'autres catégories de la soldate bien
sûr monsieur j'ai dit à nos concitoyens
j'ai dit mais j'ai pas d'idée jeunes
seulement mais les jeunes en particulier
parce qu'il veut il ya une volonté en
revanche est beaucoup de gens et en
particulier jeunes c'est pour ça que je
dis de s'engager pour des causes ce
qu'on les voit aussi assez actif je
trouve sur des causes en particulier de
la transition écologique mais d'autres
cours d'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes les questions des libertés
publiques donc on a on aura besoin dans
le débat présidentiel me semble-t-il de
revisiter ces questions et toutes ces
questions et c'est vrai que les
questions qu'on a été obligé de mettre à
l'aise je pense eux au confinement qui
est un élément de privation de liberté
d'ailleurs personne n'a dit au
gouvernement qu'on ne privait pas de
gens de liberté mais que sait il n'y a
pas un pays du monde globalement on n'a
pas été contraint de prendre des mesures
de quelques fois ensemble on associer
plus le parlement oui enfin on a associé
pas si on n'est pas rendu vraiment
pardon on est au 12e texte
12e texte ou 11e 12e texte au parlement
dans lequel on traite de ces questions
et je ne vous fais pas les offenses de
dire il ya des questions au gouvernement
mais la douzième à iter pour être
éventuellement le parlement pour être
consultée jeudi par le gouvernement l'an
dernier avec l'opposition dérégulé je
vous rappelle que le gouvernement l'an
dernier avait proposé qu'on inscrive
dans le dur de la loi que ce soit pas un
texte qui au gré des mois soit prolongé
et donc je pense qu'il n'est plus le
temps de le faire désormais mais je
regrette qu'on n'ait pas trouver les
voies et moyens pour le faire pour
tranquillement se dire quand on est face
à une crise comme celle là que nous
n'avions pas imaginé personne ni nous ni
personne quels sont les outils qu'on
peut développer pour faire en sorte
qu'on soit dans cette tension compliqués
qu'ils aient intérêt général et dans
l'intérêt général les libertés publiques
justement on peut faire ça et donc je
pense qu'il y aurait utilité alors on
est encore dans la crise reconnaissons
le même si on en sort meilleure utilité
à ce que le parlement
les gouvernants et dans la campagne
présidentielle on pense à ces sujets là
parce que ça peut revenir
malheureusement c'est un truc petites
questions qui vont dans le droit fil de
ce que disait thomas tout à l'heure pour
favoriser la participation citoyenne
votre 16 ans proposé par clément bonne
bonne idée mauvaise idée peut-être à
certaines élections oui est ce que c est
ce que c'est les jets moins cher ça ne
me gêne pas moi ça me choque pas c'est
pas si ça vous gêne juin si ce n'est pas
une idée pour intéresser les jamais je
vous non je vous dis j'essaie de vous
répondre je vous dis je suis pas buter à
l'idée que 18 à l'aura pas ça pose des
questions ça d'ailleurs été posée de la
majorité pour le vote pose d'autres
questions c'est la question de la
majorité tout couteau qui est des
questions parlons juridique mais passons
à autre chose et non comme si la
philosophie comme si ça peut exister
je pense que philosophiquement c'est pas
une gêne parce que ça permet en
particulier je pense que les jeux ne
sont plus intéressés aux élections très
nationale type présidentiel aux
élections très local municipal ça posera
la question si son qui peuvent être ils
peuvent être pardon c'est pour ça que
c'est passé ainsi peuvent être électeurs
et ceux qui peuvent être candidats bon
gars mais votre question est ce que ça
suffit si le système
si les systèmes et comme on le décrit
mon avis là non plus ça nourrit sa 9e ne
permettra pas à tout le monde ça fait
plein de choses mais c'est pour çà et là
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est le
cumul de petites choses qu'il faut faire
il faut savoir son avocat voyez le mot
est ce qu'il ya un débat en ce moment
c'est finalement le la fin du cumul des
mandats était peut-être pas le truc le
plus génial de la terre au sens où vous
avez des gens je vais reprendre le
poncif du député hors sol et que quand
on pouvait avoir un contact local
c'était quelque chose d'un peu plus oui
alors le jeu je moi je suis je peux à ce
micro dire des choses qui pourront
déplaire à certains parce que le poncif
comme vous dites du député or seuls
parce qu'il serait pas élu local on peut
ne pas être élu local et est ancré dans
le sol pardon et moi je peux le dire
sans être soupçonnable de parler pour ma
paroisse si je peux dire c'est pas sympa
j'ai connu des députés qui était député
maire et j'ai même connu des mères qui
n'était pas forcément plus ancrée que
d'autres on va dire ça comme ça vous
êtes responsables d'associations vous
êtes chef d'entreprise vous êtes citoyen
vous vivez des choses aussi bons
premiers éléments deuxième élément je
pense en revanche
moi j'étais plutôt favorable et je reste
dans la philosophie générale à l'idée
qu'on peut pas tout faire et pato cumulé
une question de temps et de
disponibilité
sauf qu'on n'a pas pensé le système en
2017 quand on a voté cette loi en se
disant comment ça marche
territorialement comment le député qui
est cercle député de la nation et qui
est plutôt là pour voter les lois et
contrôler l'action du gouvernement il
est aussi l'émanation d'un territoire
vous pouvez pas dire le député peut pas
se soucier de telles entreprises de tels
maternité de tête services d'urgence de
telles personnes qui at-elle difficultés
parce que c'est une démocratie de la
représentation et donc faut que les
citoyens aient le sentiment qu'on
comporte non seulement des valeurs des
projets des lois mais aussi comporte ce
que sont leurs problèmes spécifiques et
territoriaux et il faut qu'on trouve
alors il ya à la fois du travail sans
doute territoriale entre les
collectivités et les parlementaires est
ce qu'on a des dispositions législatives
et après une question peut-être qu'il
peut se poser deux est ce qu'on peut le
président de la république l'avait un
peu évoqué au moins des jets jeunesse
qu'il faut pas regarder non pas un cumul
député maire mais qu'on puisse être en
capacité des danses des exécutifs
maire-adjoint vice-président qui
permettent d'avoir un pied non pas
seulement dans la réalité mais dans la
façon dont ça s'emboîte parce que état
et collectivités ça travaille ensemble
contrairement à ce que disent certains
quant à ce qu'ils disent j'entends
beaucoup en particulier monsieur
bertrand dire on peut pas avoir été
président de la république sans avoir
été élu local enfin c'est une
plaisanterie pour quelqu'un qui a sans
doute se réclament du général de gaulle
et de georges pompidou enfin je veux
dire il n'ya pas besoin non plus c'est
pas une nécessité absolue je crois qu'il
faut arrêter des caricatures mais il
faut repenser ce lien je suis d'accord
france inter
acheter
question paul marc fesneau est notre
invité jusqu'à 13 heures et vous nous
avez offert une belle transition en
évoquant des noms de président de la
république en évoquant l'élection
présidentielle illustrons on va en
parler de l'élection présidentielle on
verra si l'élu futur sera lui-même
illustre vous êtes un proche d'edouard
philippe comment vous avez accueilli la
semaine dernière la
la création de son parti horizon est ce
que vous dites c'est une bonne chose
pour la majorité on vous dit tiens c'est
peut-être un peu embêtant pour mon parti
le modem au nom enfin je ne vis pas ça
comme une concurrence nous ne
connaissions pas avec edouard philippe
et nous sommes découverts en 2017 quand
j'étais président groupe et ensuite
quand j'ai été son ministre et nous
avons appris à nous connaître à nous
apprécier je crois ça c'est une chose
deuxièmement je viens plutôt de l'espace
central l'espace du centre udf puis
modem
comme beaucoup d'entre ceux qui sont qui
ont soutenu le président de la
république en 2017 edouard philippe
d'ailleurs je vous renvoie ce quelle
déclaration qui était à la fois honnête
et précises sur la création de politique
générale il disait je suis un homme de
droite donc plus à droite que vous
physiquement et politiquement
manifestement c'est ce que vous laissez
donc et au fond qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé en 2010 est au fond et en 2017
parce que nous avions et ça me permettra
de répondre à votre question parce que
nous avions pour la première fois réussi
à imposer un espace central fort des
gens qui venaient soit de la droite
comme edouard philippe soit de la gauche
comme jean yves le drian par exemple
olivier dussopt pts ont décidé de
travailler ensemble on a besoin d'un
espace de droite qui se structure et
qu'ils soient claires notamment au
moment où chez les lrg du mal à
comprendre leur ligne je parle pas d'eux
je suis adhérent je suis pas des ans
c'est assez les français jugeront delà
de la solidité des convictions dans la
durée peu importe mais on voit bien que
celle heller il ya de tension ces jeux
courts à droite toute où j'essaie plutôt
dans la droite dans ce qu'elle a été
dans son fondement ce qui était
historiquement la droite depuis des
années y compris depuis le général de
gaulle même si c'est difficile de
classer là et on a besoin structurel à
gauche parce que pour le coup là aussi
on a besoin donc l'espace a besoin de se
structurer et donc qu edouard philippe
veuille structuré cet espace là je
trouve ça très bien mais ça veut dire
qu'on peut avoir une place dans votre
grand parti qui est en train d'essayer
de sénéquier distinguons les affaires de
partie je sais que c'est un peu confus
mons et la façon dont je fus c'est bon
prince alors je vais essayer d merci
merci le set non c'est pas possible
des gens attendaient non l'idée non si
c'est un parti qui peut aller de d'un
bout à l'autre vous seriez les premiers
à le dire mais c'est l'ump qui fixe elle
n'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
d'avoir des gens à droite qui se
structure autour de formations
politiques horizons en est une des gens
qui dans l'espace central et lrm et
modem pour le coup se ressemblent à l'au
delà des patent défini et des gens qui à
gauche aussi se structure et tout ça
vient soutenir le président de la
république faut distinguer les
structures partisanes dacquois lui 2 du
de l' équilibre global qu'est la
majorité présidentielle n'a jamais été
dit que la majorité présidentielle était
l'objet d'un seul parti et d'un mono
l'immense vague la
météo il ya un problème idéologique
c'est à dire qu'on voit
edouard philippe arrivé avec son
idéologie de droite et on sent que le
pôle central n'a pas structurée du tout
son idéologie peut-être parce que trop
en soutien du président de la république
l'humanisme que défendent et françois
bayrou pendant toute sa carrière
politique elle n'est pas tellement à
l'affirmer aujourd'hui et est ce que du
coup vous allez pas vous faire
complètement mangés par les structures
et maladroite moi ça fait 25 ans que
j'adhère à peu près la même formation
politique dans le même espace si je
devais avoir peur d'être mangés
maintenant c'est que vraiment j'aurais
peur de pas grand chose j'ai vu bien les
situations plus dangereuse pour la
comment dirais-je pour l'existence même
de cette famille de pensée parfois l'ump
tout à l'heure oui et nous étions
parfois seul à gauche et à droite avec
des gens qui nous regardent un 10 ans
c'est très bien on pourrait travailler
ensemble sauf qu'il restait toujours
dans leur canton moi j'ai peur de rien
sur le sujet quand on est à peu près
solide dans ses convictions et
comportait un courant de pensée vous
avez raison l'humanisme ça existe c'est
hip hop mais vous trouvez que ça
attendez affirmé l'un d'eux ça existe
aussi dans le
l'action que nous avons menée depuis
quatre ans pardon en fin je il ya un
certain nombre de sujets on a parlé de
pouvoir d'achat on a parlé du dos n'a
pas parlé mais on pourrait parler du
dédoublement des classes on pourrait
parler de la re conquête territoriale
qui a été menée dans bien des sujets
territoire d'industrie des opérations
coeur devant les maisons français avis
qui vise à rapprocher le service public
des citoyens si ça c'est pas une
conception humaniste alors je sais pas
ce que la conception humaniste donc les
revenus leur valorisation d'un certain
nombre d'allocations alors les mêmes qui
vous font la leçon dise pas qu'il
n'avait rien fait pendant cinq dix ou
quinze ans nous avons revalorisé
incertain de la collation de location
donc dans la politique que nous avons
menée il y avait de l'humanisme
troisième chose edouard philippe enfin
edouard philippe n'apparaît pas sur la
scène publique doit philippe il était
premier ministre d'un gouvernement
auquel je suis fière d'avoir appartenu
donc il n'est pas un objet nouveau dans
la dans le dans l'écosystème
présidentielle et donc il à lui sa
philosophie y porte un certain nombre de
choses nous portons des choses l'ordre
est ce la seule chose dans les comptes
la seule chose sur laquelle je suis
assez aligna est ce que vous dites c'est
qu'au fond le paysage politique cds
structurés en 2017 et globalement le
pôle it et paysage politique partout
nulle part pardon ne s'est restructurée
et donc on a deux régions c'est une
bonne nouvelle et c'est long
et c'est ce qui fait la méfiance de
certains profils parce que à droite va
chez les élèves ils n'ont pas réglé
leurs lignes stratégiques et à gauche je
ne vois pas de restructuration je fais
pas la leçon simplement c'est un fait et
dans l'espace qui s'était créée autour
du président de la république peut-être
nous n'avions pas assez oeuvrait dans la
restructuration est donc je partage
votre point de vue mais c'est pas la
confusion edouard philippe vient d
horizon de la droite et c'est très bien
tu as mon jeu je suis pas pour
l'effacement de la droite et la gauche
je suis juste pour dire qu'il ya des
gens qui dans des moments particuliers
comme ceux qu'on vit ont besoin d'être
autre chose que catégoriser à droite à
gauche et pour ce faire l'espace
pour ça que nous vous n'êtes pas du coup
responsables aussi de 7 vous évoquez ce
paysage complètement morcelé
politiquement est-ce que c'est pas
précisément en cassant la gauche et la
droite que vous avez créé aussi les
conditions de l'émergence 12 bits sans
avoir dit le mot de figure on pense
évidemment eric zemmour ou à d'autres
oui enfin pardonnez moi
on
n'est pas dans la sphère de l'oeuf ou la
poule pour le coup c'est la droite et la
gauche qui se sont cassés elle-même
pardon c'est l'incapacité en nous
vendant
enfin quand même ils ont pendant 25 ans
on nous expliquait que c'était leur
alternance qui changerait la vie et qu'à
chaque fois on pouvait rien faire c'est
les échecs successifs de la droite et de
la gauche qui ont fait ce qu avait tenté
de faire émerger françois bayrou en
particulier en 2007 en 2007 il s'était
passé quelque chose et qu'est ce qui
s'était passé il s'était passé
simplement que à droite et à gauche il
s'était trouvé personne pour dire au
fond ce que dit bayrou est juste et
pourquoi beaucoup le pensent et à
l'époque il ya sûrement des gens ici qui
s'en souviennent beaucoup pensé bayrou
avait raison dès 2007 pourquoi parce
qu'on voyait l'échec de la droite et de
la gauche et qu'au fond la ligne aux
deux idéologies qu'à droite et à gauche
n'était pas clair si vous pouvez me
trouver des points communs je veux pas
donner de noms mais entre certains à
droite et certains à gauche dans le même
formation politique ils disent pas la
même chose il pense pas la même chose il
faut qu'ils clarifient et c'est ça qui a
procuré produits le bouleversement 2017
avec une émergence dans l'espace central
et c'est ça qu'il faut consolider c'est
juste le baptême c'est pourquoi on
conteste effectivement le grand parti va
naître parce qu'on est
ensemble on ont évoqué je pense qu'ils
ont raison parce que il faut que ce soit
à la fois dans la séquence
présidentielle mais aussi montrer que
c'est au delà de cette séquence là et
c'est pas seulement la séquence
législative d'ailleurs ce courant de
pensée la besoin se structurer et donc
ils ont dit avant noël et je suis assez
d'accord même avant avant noël juste de
françois bayrou quand on l'a reçue le
premier week-end de septembre avait
annoncé mi octobre dont vous avez reculé
d'un mois mais il a redit il a redit un
mois et demi de nom il y là il est
contredit récemment y compris à avignon
et même à guidel que c'est l horizon qui
s'était donné on attelle et syncrétique
faudrait savoir ya une évolution de l'
attitude par rapport à eric zemmour
tapez ne plus tapés négliger ne plus
négliger vous en êtes où pour l'instant
première question moyennement quels sont
selon vous les thèmes qui domineront la
campagne est ce que sont des thèmes
comme régalien puisque c'est le rêve des
règlements de structures l idéologie et
l'opinion autour d'eux des thèmes qu'il
met sur le tapis ou est-ce que vous
pensez que ça sera différent euh je
passe une évolution je vais vous dire
moi ce qui m'a le plus vu depuis le
début je n'ai pas envie de parler de
quelqu'un qui n'est pas candidat et que
je n'ai pas un visa peut subir de dire
ça mais pour me demander mon sentiment
les images de sa jeunesse j'ai pas dit
que ça allait suffire vous avez raison
et en même temps je n'ai pas envie que
la vie politique française et par
respect compris pour les autres
candidats se résuma qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la dernière phrase de la
dernière insulte c'est justement
attendait c'est notre deuxième partie de
questions allez-y si j'ai bien compris
donc moi je pense qu'il faut que chacun
développe ses idées je pense qu'on n'a
aucun intérêt à aller chercher et elle
est en permanence en réponse pour lui
comme pour d'autres comment dirais-je en
réponse aux autres il faut être con et
dire ce qu'on veut faire premiers
éléments deuxième élément est ce que les
thèmes - puisque ses corollaires un peu
dans votre question je vois bien qu'eric
zemmour hui il est à la fois sur les
thèmes régala il est surtout sur des
thèmes qui viennent fracturé la société
enfin ce qu'ils cherchaient l'angle qui
permet de dire de consolider des voix
qu'ils soient des causes des voix contre
telle ou telle catégorie population bon
je pense que quand on veut être
président la pp il faut faire exactement
l'inversé les grands présidents la
république qu'on a eue ils ont plutôt
été des présidents l'appliquant essayer
de consolider de rassembler même si
c'est parfois difficile que de diviser
on dit toujours ça que le thème les
thèmes régalien je pense que c'est un
mix de choses il ya sans doute les
questions
comment dirais-je d'indépendance et
c'est pas que des thèmes c'est des
thèmes économiques
c'est des thèmes internationaux c'est
comme on assume dans des espaces sont
des espaces éminemment souhaite attirer
les thèmes de souveraineté sont des
souvent des thèmes qui pour les français
sont des thèmes très important les
thèmes d'identité au bon sens du terme
non pas sur qu est-ce que c'est le passé
ce que moi je suis très à l'aise avec la
question des racines j'ai vraiment aucun
sujet et que ce sujet là mais il faut
qu'on se projette aussi c'est qu'est ce
qu'on a envie de défendre comme société
donc je pense que ça aussi c'est des
thèmes qui sont importants évidemment
les thèmes de la sécurité sont des
thèmes importants et au fond il ya des
thèmes on voit bien que la difficulté
désormais c'est qu'on est dans une
société je suis pas tf1 médias on est
tous responsables sont vraiment les uns
une société de l'immédiateté et ou font
un thème peu émergé en 15 jours et il
avait disparu
depuis six mois c'est comme ça il se
trouverait que nous aurions un événement
climatique très puissant j'imagine que
le thème or pourtant c'est un thème en
tant que tel du dérèglement climatique
nous aurions des inondations comme les
allemands je pense que le thème
remontrer non
faut essayer si je sais que c'est
compliqué moi-même j'essaie de m'y
astreindre dans la vie publique regardez
ce que sont les thèmes de fond ce que
vous avez évoqué ce qu'on a essayé
d'évoquer depuis tout à l'heure pour
éviter d'être à courir derrière des
thèmes qui sont faits par une actualité
qui est tellement mondialisé est
tellement immédiate et après on subit
donc vous dites qu'il est sûr est belle
mais finalement un peu là moi j'ai pas
il faudra qu'il réponde à d'autres
questions que celle qui met en
permanence au débat c'est qu'est ce
qu'il fait pour le pouvoir d'achat
qu'est ce qu'il fait pour la réforme de
l'état qu'est ce qui fait peser que les
quatre ans
au fond du dispositif aussi actuel qui
au fond le président de la république
entrera un moment campagne avec ses
thèmes et en attendant d'assez pas de
lui qu occupe le terrain et ce sont des
thèmes portés par des candidats au fond
auquel vous avez beaucoup de matches
j'aurai ce que voulait dire la précieuse
mais si jamais on le président de la
république était officiellement candidat
en campagne d'ailleurs il n'est pas de
tradition que ce sera fait comme ça non
mais vous par exemple vous les gens
autour de lui en fait y'a quand même un
parti il ya mais je pense que c'est lié
le rôle et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il faut travailler sur cette question
partisane c'est le rôle des formations
politiques et des responsables publics
que nous sommes n'ont pas de préempter
le débat présidentiel mais de dire des
choses dans le moment du débat qu'on a
parce que j'essayais de faire devant
vous aujourd'hui il faut qu'on ait du
débat public est ce qu'on soit pas
simplement à regarder se dérouler les
shows l'isq alors en plus cela c'est la
faiblesse du système mac conquis par
céder ce n'est pas le système mac os
enfin je veux dire vous découvrez pas
comme moi qu'on est dans un système
présidentiel où tout procède d'un
système précédent
respiration de la faisait la blanche
règne de mitterrand qu'il soit candidat
ou de la structuration où la structure
non mais j'entends ce que vous dites
mais je dis ou la structuration de la
vie publique en france elle est faite
autour de la figure présidentielle aidé
à la présidence de la république et la
campagne présidentielle c'est comme ça
peut regretter on peut dire la
constitution 58 n'est pas parfaite c'est
ce qu'on a sous les yeux mais en même
temps que nous soyons que nous ne
subissions pas c'est ce que vous disiez
un peu c'est ce qu'on ne subissent pas
là la campagne des autres je trouve
effectivement il faut qu'on dise des
choses dans le débat public et je pense
qui au fur et à mesure faut qu'on dise
des choses mais ne présentons pas de
campagne présidentielle parce que pour
les raisons que vous indiquez c'est
difficile aujourd'hui à date le 17
octobre de dire ce que seront compte
tenu de ce qu'est l'état de fébrilité
permanent qu'on a sur ces sujets là
quels seront les sujets qui au final
auront nous et accompagne présidence
est-ce que c'est pas un peu risqué
d'apparaître et c'est peut-être une
dernière question de seule question
politique d'apparaître comme le camp de
l'humanisme et de la raison est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un risque d' arrogance à risque
de refuser le débat d'arrogance n'ont
vraiment pas faim jeu je partage assez
ce qu'a dit et je vais je vais le
compléter ce qu'a dit clairement gones
sur ces questions sur la question de la
raison on a besoin quand même d'avoir
des débats publics j'ai vu je sais plus
dans quel journal la volonté d'avoir une
forme d'exigence que vous portez en
particulier dans le service public c'est
la grand plaisir la gueule de la croix
je trouve que c'est assez juste je pense
qu'il faut qu'on je sais que vous portez
pour beaucoup cette exigence de pas être
soumis aux réseaux sociaux et à cette
loi là pour essayer de nouer des débats
publics ont peu à peu ses tripes et
gentiment dire des choses différentes
être dans la contradiction sans
s'insulter dans invectives et la
violence est ce que ça produit ou moi
j'ai jamais pensé que j'allais faire de
la vie politique un terrain c'était
comme ça de boxe violent c'est n'empêche
pas de dire des choses et marquer des
différences avec plein de gens c'est pas
le sujet on s'en fiche pas dessus donc
on a besoin dans ce moment-là de
construire de constructa je pense qu'on
a il faut qu'on fasse attention à
structurer les choses autour de débats
qu'ils soient des débats qui au bout
rassemble voyez ce que je veux dire et
c'est ça qui va être la difficulté de
l'exercice qui est devant nous parce que
si on n'arrive pas à dire posément les
choses évidemment on ira vers des
solutions extrêmes c'est ça que je
pourrais vous dire c'est bon de vous
attaquer
faut jamais être inquiet je pense qu'on
a besoin à la fois de dire ce qu'on peut
faire du pays ce qu'on veut en faire et
ça c'est plutôt la part de la raison et
en même temps faut porter une forme de
passion française n'est pas la passion
déraisonnable pas la passion qui produit
la querelle et la haine de l'autre la
passion qui fait qu'on aime son pays
comme je laime comme les membres du
gouvernement et comme tous les français
l'aiment et donc c'est cette veillée
c'est cette balance entre la raison de
ne pas dire n'importe quoi et donc la
nécessité d'avoir des débats sérieux et
la passion parce que quand on aime son
pays on a envie qu'il avance et donc on
a envie d'y aller fort
de dire avec des mots qu'il soit fort si
cette balance là qu'il faut trouver la
passion raisonnable de la france de marc
raynaud qui a été notre invité depuis
midi sur questions politiques merci
beaucoup à tout les 3 merci pour les
quais latéraux merci marc fesneau merci
alexandre gilardi jean philippe balasse
et alexandre chan et à la réalisation on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de questions politiques